the reason why there is a surging
interest into the topic of lost ancient
human civilizations by millions of
people from around the world is because
the more you research the little known
and unexplainable details particularly
among the ancient Egyptians you quickly
become aware of the bizarre reality that
they had to have possessed some unknown
form of lost ancient technology and this
ancient stone box you're seeing here is
just one piece of evidence that
illustrates that we truly have no idea
how the Egyptians cut and carved massive
Granite stones and this large yet
little-known Granite box which is now on
display at the Cairo Museum in Egypt is
said to have been abandoned by the
Egyptians due to mistake in the cut as
you see here thus forcing them to
discard and move on to another block of
stone but as the saying goes the devil
is in the details and this off-centered
slanted cut which is the reason why it
is said to have been discarded is
actually strong supportive evidence that
they were using a method of tooling that
far exceeds anything known or believed
to have been possible to have been
possessed by the ancient Egyptians
because make no mistake if this error
had been done with a slow primitive
copper-based saw as has been widely
theorized and in fact intensely claimed
by modern researchers then surely the
Ancients cutting this Stone would have
noticed the error and corrected it far
sooner I mean let's not forget that when
the alleged copper-based saws were
tested on granite by Leading
egyptologists the results proved to be
so unbelievably slow that it's
remarkable that some still choose to
even suggest it in fact during this
demonstration they were only able to cut
at a rate of four millimeters an hour
which is so astonishingly slow that it's
not even remotely feasible I mean do the
math and four millimeters an hour
equates to less than one inch every 6
six hours of Non-Stop labor-filled
handwork so if that were actually the
case then clearly the people cutting
this Stone would have noticed the air
immediately in fact at this slow rate
they would have noticed the mistake
literally days ahead of time and would
have not continued to cut this stone
block without surely noticing the
inaccuracy that is unless they were
using a method of tooling that cuts at a
rate that is far far quicker than what
we're aware of or even thought was
possible and like I've shared countless
times in other videos but it cannot be
overstated this especially when we
consider that many people are just now
learning about these details for the
first time so to be clear not only did
we never find bronzaws of this size or
shape but the Egyptians never even
annotated them in hieroglyphs like they
did with practically everything else in
fact these small saws and various
tooling you're seeing here are the only
examples that we did find and moreover
the only times the Egyptians did show
bronze cutting anything was on wood to
create furniture and by the way with the
same type of small saws that we did
indeed find in our now on display in
museums
you see this is one of the things that
makes this topic so interesting in that
most people are totally unaware that the
Egyptians left us with literally zero
explanation as to how they cut and
carved Stone
you have to admit that is a bit weird
when you think about it and the reality
is that the only reason why this slow
primitive method is still discussed is
because the so-called experts are at a
total loss for other possibilities well
why is that well because again we found
literally nothing else it is a complete
and total mystery even to this day which
leaves us in the bizarre reality that
the ancient Egyptians must have
possessed some other type of tooling to
achieve their incredible stonework you
see this is why studying this topic as
an adult is so important in that it
paints you a far more realistic
understanding into the existing
Mysteries and unanswered questions
related to the ancient Egyptians and so
when we consider this lengthy error in
the form of a off-centered saw cut we
have to ask ourselves a big question
which is does it make any feasible sense
that this air would have gone unnoticed
if they were cutting the stone with the
slow primitive method that is so
adamantly claimed or is it more likely
that there was some other type of
tooling a technology of some kind that
was possessed by the Ancients that is
somehow unknown to us even to this day
and by the way like I've mentioned
before technology does not have to
involve lasers or something crazy in
fact the shoes that we wear on our feet
are a form of Technology a saddle on a
horse is a form of Technology we have to
think outside the box and technology is
anything that helps improve our lives so
again the reality is that the evidence
is right in front of us and it is
apparent to those who take the time to
research the more nuanced details like I
always say look and think for yourself
the mystery is real now I briefly
mentioned this Stone box in a video I
made last year but it was at the tail
end of a more lengthy video so not
everyone got a chance to see it but this
box is certainly deserving of a form of
discussion of its own and it's
unfortunate that more people are not yet
aware of it as the implications are
truly enormous and that any reasonable
person can conclude that this was not
created by bronze hand saws which like I
said is still adamantly claimed by the
so-called experts even to this day
because it's not just obvious I mean
like I mentioned a moment ago it's been
tested and debunked so clearly it's not
the method and and if we're talking
science here
like to push these bronze stooling
theories at this point is pseudoscience
and I'm starting to think that certain
people's careers and the people who are
writing these textbooks and making
excellent money are their thought
process is being influenced because of
which because clearly I mean honestly if
these silly copper-based saws are the
best explanation that the so-called
experts can come up with then maybe just
maybe they're not qualified to be
experts in this field or at least I
should say that a true expert would
simply say I don't know because that's
the correct answer we don't know the
Egyptians didn't tell us how they did it
and it's still a mystery is it really
that hard to say now with all that said
if you haven't seen my video from two
weeks ago you'll definitely want to go
check that one out because when you
realize that this right here is the
oldest largest and best preserved boat
ever found from ancient Egypt you have
to start asking questions as to how did
the Ancients move Stones as large as one
thousand tons down the Nile River over
on boats as has been widely accepted and
we must also ask ourselves why are there
no depictions even showing how the
Egyptians could have moved such
massively heavy Stones down the Nile
River in the first place again go check
out that video for some
thought-provoking content now that aside
I have some very important information
and I plead for your attention for just
a moment now as I mentioned at the end
of my last video I am diversifying I am
expanding until alternative Tech
platforms and I need your support now
YouTube is still my home but moving
forward I am uploading all my videos to
my patreon subscribe star and locals
account I'll have links down below a day
ahead of time so I'll give my loyal
supporters a chance to view these first
and give something back in return for
those who are so supportive of me and
also on those platforms I will be
sharing and uploading exclusive content
that will not be here on YouTube Because
as I mentioned before I am
highly concerned about the future and
there's so many things I want to say and
discuss but these topics are getting
people censored and banned and I have a
real problem with that so in other words
I YouTube's still home but if you want
to hear my opinions on many many other
topics because that's something I've
been struggling with guys is that I love
the Ancients but like there's so many
other topics that I want to discuss as
well I want to do a bunch of things and
the feeling of not being able to discuss
certain topics out of fear of being
censored really bothers me so hence it's
time to freaking get creative so again
find the links down below locals.com
awesome so I've been working with their
execs and I couldn't be more excited
patreon by the way I've heard all kinds
of terrible things about their
censorship so let me just say I would
rather have you support me on locals or
subscribe star but I'll stay on patreon
as long as they let me
um so it's up to you A lot of people
don't even want to put anything on there
um but something else because I keep
getting comments people that are
surprised that are just becoming aware
of it but I'm really excited to say that
I was on a couple podcasts not long ago
one of which was Joe Rogan it's on
Spotify for free I got the link down
below and I was also on Danica Patrick's
podcast you'll remember Danica Patrick
famous racing star awesome person that's
totally into all these same topics so go
check that out so links for everything I
just described down in the description
as well as the pinned comments
um but I'm gonna close it up there I've
been working on a number of other things
uh multitasking on creating all these
other platforms for me to expand onto so
uh stay tuned I got some exciting videos
in the works but the Reason by the way
you should support me on those platforms
is because I'm going to be doing
podcasts live q and A's and just
uploading like I said other content that
you won't find on YouTube but again
YouTube is still home but to anyone that
supports me you'll get a chance to see
these videos first but anyways I'm Jimmy
corsetti my channel is called bright
Insight leave a comment and share your
thoughts on this Stone box clearly
bronze saws are not the method guys the
Egyptians didn't say they did it we
never found proof to even suggest they
did do it why is it still being being
pushed like
leave a comment I want to hear your
thoughts hit the like button subscribe
I'll close it up there take care
everybody